the fact that request animation frame
runs once and only once during a redraw
cycle also lets the browser optimize
concurrent animations
svg css transitions scrolling your own
dom based manipulation together into a
single reflow and repaint cycle rather
than each of these poking in in its own
timer and updating the screen whenever
it feels like this leads to much higher
fidelity visual refreshes
but in addition to causing all these
refreshes together this has the effect
of locking the updates to the visual
refresh rate as a maximum you won't
accidentally call your drawing routine
more than once during that magic 16.7
millisecond long refresh cycle which
would waste work request animation frame
won't be called again until the current
frame is pushed out to the screen and
it's ready for another frame and then
finally there's one more key feature to
request animation frame your callback
won't be called if the browser tab isn't
visible
that is if you're running the animation
loop in a tab and the user switches away
the browser won't keep calling the
visual refresh callback it will once
it's visible again but this means you
won't be using the cpu the gpu or extra
memory potentially which will lead to
longer battery life on a mobile device